avenue in the heart of tunisia's
diplomatic area
has long been the stage for protests and
political change
and this week was no different
security forces lined the streets and
the army has set up barricades
blocking people and politicians from
accessing government buildings
president kaizeid sacked the prime
minister
other prominent cabinet members and
announced a freeze on parliament for 30
days
he says the decision was taken after
following the process laid out
by the constitution but the move has
divided opinions
if the people see that kaiser wants to
become a dictator and work against the
revolution
of course the people rise up against him
and overthrow him
it is really a rescue operation because
lately all tunisians have seen that the
economic and social situation has
deteriorated a lot
under the government's policies the
biggest political group the anahata
party
is calling the president's move a coup
but says it's
open and ready for dialogue
we reject these unconstitutional
announcements and we
welcome all the rejections that have
come from
most other tunisian political parties as
well as civil society organizations
and we call on the tunisian people to
be calm and vigilant and be ready to
defend
their democracy
mass protests were held on sunday with
many focusing their anger at the anata
party
a long struggle with covert 19 and an
economy in decline
has become a perfect recipe for unrest
then on monday a face-off in tunis
between those for
and against the president these same
streets were filled during the 2011
jasmine revolution that led to a decade
of democracy
but the people now in power are being
accused of corruption
and incompetence
[Applause]
and the president is accused of
establishing an authoritarian government
that many people here fought so hard to
rid of a decade ago
for now what is important is that the
decision for all the
political actions to sit together that
we are no longer within an authoritarian
regime
in tunisia but we are in democratic
regime in tunisia and everything has to
happen within that democratic process
and democratic
framework for now tunis is calm many
don't know whether
its fragile democracy can be saved by
dialogue
or whether the streets will once again
become a stage
for a nation demanding change laura
burton manly al jazeera